[Music]
Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny take their
new romance to NYC and a source tells
E.T why they're getting closer and
closer every day goodbye happiness
nothing anything complicated the two
walk the 2023 Met Gala red carpet
separately on Monday but came together
to attend the after party Kendall
trading in her pantless bodysuit for
this sheer strapless one with a black
thong over it yep leaving little to the
imagination oh my God just be cool it's
fine as for bunny he changed out of his
white suit into something more casual a
suede jacket and brown pants
[Music]
hair clearly going strong our source
says candy and Bad Bunny talk and text
Non-Stop and see each other whenever
it's possible it's really exciting The
Source ads are definitely getting more
smitten as they spend more time together
I like to keep my private life pretty
private so I try my best but at the same
time I don't I don't like to let being
seen out in public with someone like
affect my everyday life
seems Kendall's changing her tune since
sparking dating Rumors in February she
and Bad Bunny have been spotted on Sushi
dates horseback rides attending concerts
together the model even supported him at
Coachella and the pair kinda went
Instagram official in this Wild Golf
Cart video
[Music]
and a couple days before Fashion's
biggest night Bad Bunny and Kenny hit up
a hookah bar in the Big Apple in style
of course well what kind of qualities
are you looking for in a relationship
everything
all is about you know be honest always
be honest our source says Bad Bunny
makes Kendall laugh and she's always
smiling around him adding he's also a
big romantic which she finds very
attractive and sweet I'm a good guy
I'm cute
quote he genuinely just makes her happy
and there is no drama
[Music]